welcome back to New rockstars I'm Eric
Boss and Thor love and thunder takes us
to church with a delightfully weird mix
of gods some whose veins pump the same
blood as ours except gold While others
more abstract with trailers months ago
officially confirming a specific
grouping of cosmic entities would factor
into this movie's plot but spoiler
warning before I continue along with
beans like the Living Tribunal The
Watcher death Eon and infinity more
Cosmic representational statues populate
this chamber and at the heart of it is
eternity a figure who in Thor love and
thunder Gore successfully meets in the
film's most ethereal and mysterious
sequence using eternity to resurrect his
daughter who now represents the Marvel
Cosmic entity of love and in the film's
final scene love joins her Anki Thor at
his side as the titular love and thunder
but to quote these screaming goats of
this movie at least what I assume
they're saying
going on let's explain who eternity is
in Marvel Comics what changes Thor love
and thunder made to Eternity in the MCU
and what this means for the MCU Cosmic
Landscape in the future and really how
love factors into all this because it is
what the world needs now no not just for
some but for everyone in the world of in
Thunder's opening sequence Gore's
daughter passes away she's actually
played by Chris Hemsworth's real-life
daughter India rose Hemsworth and she
dies despite Gore's desperate prayers to
their God rapu and when Gore finally
meets rapu rapu mocks him and the Necker
sword carried by the other entity whom
rappu killed calls out to gore to kill
all gods and to seek the heart of
Eternity to do so and then go receive
some premonitions of this plan to use
the bifrost from Stormbreaker to open a
portal in the heart of eternity's
half-mast statue later on in omnipotent
City Zeus assures everyone that Gore
could never reach eternity and Valkyrie
explains to Jane eternity is a very
powerful Cosmic being at the center of
the universe it will grant the desire of
the first person who reaches it Jane
asks so it's like a wishing well Gore
ends up taking Stormbreaker and uses the
body Frost to blast open that portal
walk through it even though he's dying
because the neck Resort's been destroyed
at this point and we see eternity's true
form in a sunny waterline realm that it
sounds like they actually shot in a Best
Buy parking lot this place actually
looks a lot like thanos's Soul realm
except with the sky the normal color The
Eternity here looks about 20 feet tall
and as in the comics appears as a
silhouette with a cloak curved antlers
and the vague Visage of a face his body
containing stars and planets and
galaxies so like all the cosmic figures
in this chamber the statue form is
really a representation of the truer
more ethereal form now eternity never
says a word in this movie really just
sits legs folded in the sen-like state
it wordlessly grants Gore's wish to
resurrect his daughter who first appears
as an eternity-like Reflection In The
Water this girl is implied to be love
another abstract Cosmic entity in the
Marvel Comics korg's final narration
states that she has the powers of a God
she was born from eternity and he names
her love looks like she can fire some
purple colored optic Blast from her eyes
now in the comics eternity was
introduced as the creation of Stan Lee
and artist Steve ditko under the 60s
Strange Tales title sought by Doctor
Strange who is believed to be the first
human to make contact with eternity
eternity is really considered an
all-powerful Cosmic entity the living
embodiment of the Multiverse itself who
can incarnate anything into reality just
by thinking it later Comics established
that eternity came about after a
previous first being the first firmament
who created the aspirants who created
the celestials and then a cosmic war
broke out among all these tears
destroying that first universe but the
fragments of that later coalesced into a
new Multiverse that became to be known
as eternity within the cosmic hierarchy
eternity is considered the brother to
Infinity who is actually one of the
other entities in that chamber the
relative power scales tend to shift
depending on the narrative needs of the
story these beings show up in but
generally eternity is close to the top
of the hierarchy but considered beneath
beings like the one above all or the
Living Tribunal The Living Tribunal of
course the Supreme judge who can
overrule anything he's been making
plenty cameos lately in Multiverse of
Madness and Loki Thor 11 Thunder
actually shows these seven entities
along alongside each other in the
chamber including the celestial form of
the one above all the statue head that
collapses and almost crushes the kids
but the fact that they all share this
chamber implies that they might check
and balance each other and share a kind
of equal status presumably the bifrost
could have opened portals in all of them
like a portal in the Living Tribunal
statue to chat with them or a portal in
The Watcher statue to chat with Jeffrey
Wright eternity in the comics actually
shows up in various Cosmic events but
has never really been considered a kind
of wishing well until now in this movie
but the fact that in love and thunder
eternity grants this desire of the first
person who reaches it suggests that
there's some kind of legend or backstory
to Eternity in the MCU that Eternity for
some reason was waiting for one person
to reach him and might have wanted to
transfigure himself into a new form of
love and if you step back and look at
where the MCU is right now I think we
can figure out why although this is the
first time we're seeing eternity's true
form in the MCU there have been a few
references to Eternity like in the first
Guardians of the Galaxy the art on the
walls of the Temple of Morag includes
Engravings of four figures figures we
later seen close-up in the collector's
story figures representing eternity
Infinity entropy and death and in
Guardians Volume 2 when the celestial
ego connects with Peter Quill and
Peter's eyes were opened to the broader
nature of the cosmos his eyes fill with
stars and he says
[Music]
James Gunn has clarified that Peter was
referring to eternal life not
necessarily the capital E Cosmic being
but still the MCU has been expanding
into this Cosmic Direction with the
introduction of the celestials beings
that predated the Big Bang according to
the eternal's prologue so eternity might
have been a veteran of a past War before
the Big Bang maybe resulting in the Big
Bang eternity along with these other
beings might have reached to truce with
the celestials leaving the celestials to
maintain the universe while eternity and
these other entities are forced into a
kind of Exile to watch and to never
intervene which could be why we've never
really seen them until now and why it
was such a violation for The Watcher to
intervene in what if so why was eternity
depicted as a wishing well waiting for
one person to reach him and then kind of
expire well first off maybe this isn't
for us to question why sad boys want to
whisper their secrets into wishing wells
on days when he said too much he'll lean
on it and contemplate his reflection
so what is he putting in there
a secret
so this watery realm that we're now in
may be the latest example of a realm in
the MCU alternate universe is being just
kind of doppelgangers variants of our
universe Realms being more ethereal
surreal looking buffer zones in between
with some spiritual afterlife
implications like the ancestral plane
the quantum realm talo the duat and now
expand into Realms like the Nord
dimension of Ms Marvel and Valhalla in
this movie's post-credits scene this
realm might be the dimension of
manifestations from the comics that is
eternity's realm from the 90s Quasar
Comics that tells us more about the
eternity lore so again Valkyrie states
that eternity is at the center of the
universe and to reach eternity it must
mean that the established order of the
MCU has so eroded that the bifrost
something previously considered sacred
confined to the All Fathers and Asgard
controlled only by Heimdall that now the
bifrost has fallen into self-interested
hands I mean think about it even the
creation of Stormbreaker by Gore and
entry could be seen as a kind of
sacrilegious Resort a weapon that can
kill Gods why would you ever need that
unless [ __ ] has really hit the fan the
pie for us should never be something
that is this portable you can't blame
Zeus and the other Olympian gods for
thinking this would never happen so From
eternity's perspective for someone to
reach him it must be a sign that the
universe is giving off a death rattle
that its time is up eternity as being
unaffected by time knows where this is
all headed like he who remains foreseen
the sacred timeline unraveling the Kang
variants maybe even wanting that to
happen planning it to happen causing it
and then now we're seeing him as Marvel
the predestined closed loop of kamalacan
going back in time to save her own
grandmother and allow for her own
existence time is certainly a flat
circle in the MCU and that's absolutely
how eternity sees it he knows there's no
point for maintaining a clearly outlying
boundary of reality when incursions
between universes between Realms between
timelines are increasing so what does
eternity do he grants one wish and
transforms himself from something the
universe no longer needs boundaries into
something the Multiverse will
desperately need going forward love and
we initially see love and the reflection
as eternity's story form tells us that
eternity lives on in her but in an
active form to help this growing
Multiverse feel compassion for each
other hey the best way to support new
rockstars is with our new Thor inspired
latest Obsession shirt and new
rockstarsmerch.com follow me on
Instagram and Twitter at a boss
following Rockstar subscribe to new
Rockstar some more analysis of
everything you love thanks for watching
bye
[Music]
foreign
[Music]